ces derniers s'ils cessent de sciences
super bien reçu
merci c'est c'est super super chaud mois
attendre un peu tu vas me passer une
paille je vais voir ça comme il peinait
vous allez voir rien de plus agaçant que
de devoir attendre qu'un café
refroidissent ou qu'une classe
ramollissent avant de les déguster
moment on a fait tous l'expérience
essayer de les engloutir direct ça peut
être sacrément désagréable alors
imaginez un peu le calvaire
si vous deviez boire des litres d'une
boisson bouillante le plus rapidement
possible la vidéo que vous venez doit
être un terme au gramme de la punaise
rudin us pro lexus en train de boire du
sang de moutons à travers la paroi d'un
alimentateur artificiel ce genre de
vidéos permet de révéler la température
et on s'aperçoit ici que alors que
l'insecte bois du son à 37 degrés
celsius sa température reste de 22
degrés dans la majeure partie de son
corps heureusement parce que ces
punaises ne peuvent pas supporter des
excès de chaleur au delà de 30 degrés
celsius
pire si elles étaient plusieurs à
proximité des voisines pourrait les
confondre avec des mammifères gorgés de
sang et commencer à les cannibaliser
mais comment font-elles pour éviter le
coup de chaud des chercheurs de
l'université françois rabelais de tours
associé à des équipes brésiliennes et
canadiennes ont découvert leur secret
tout se passe au bout du roster la sorte
de paille qu'utilise la punaise pour se
gorger de sang au niveau de la tête
l'oesophage et coller à une aorte dans
laquelle circulent les fluides frais de
l'insecte cette configuration créé ce
qu'on appelle un système des changes de
chaleur à contre-courant et permet de
refroidir le 115 gurgy que la punaise
avant qu'il n'arrive dans son abdomen si
je colle mapaï cherchell de l'oea
alors que j'apprécie quick a fait moins
chaud
la boisson dieu lui parviendra plus
tiédasse pinaise plus chaud des systèmes
d' échange de chaleur à contre-courant
il en existe dans les chaudières dans
votre frigo dans votre climatiseur est
dans la nature on en connaissait dans le
museau des gazelles ou encore dans les
nageurs des dauphins mais c'est la
première fois qu'on en met en évidence
chez un insecte qui boit du sang encore
plus fort il semblerait que ces punaises
compile plusieurs manières à d'évacuer
le surplus de chaleur en utilisant un
système de refroidissement grâce à leur
pipi c'est une goutte de pipi reste au
bout de leur abdomen et s'évapore cela
va leur permettre d'évacuer de la
chaleur c'est d'ailleurs la même
technique qu'avait mis en évidence
l'équipe de chercheurs de l'université
françois rabelais de tours qui l'avait
découverte chez des moustiques anophèles
eux aussi confrontés aux risques de
surchauffe
lorsqu'elle nous pompent l'eau sans
moustiques et punaise buveurs de sang
sont des vecteurs de nombreuses maladies
maria qui est colporté par l'anophèle ou
encore la maladie de chagas transmises
par cette punaise ouais je sais c'est
chaud mais heureusement qu'on en apprend
plus sur leur manière de se nourrir pour
pouvoir mieux les affronter je voulais
sur ses espoirs mais si vous voulez
battre le fer quand il est encore chaud
vous pouvez nous laisser un commentaire
à chaud ça nous fera au coeur
ça ne me fait ni chaud ni froid abonnez
vous élisez moi parasites